come on kick it go oh this is easy
Annie the famous actor that we met at
the airport about eight years ago who
only acted we've ever met at an airport
who's famous Bobby Flay
not an actor this fellow was in front of
us at the sbarro we were wondering why I
was in the first-class lounge oh yes yes
god damn it max there's a whole room of
people to help you honor who's us
good point he was a Incredible Hulk Eric
Bana other one um
Mark Ruffalo other one Lou Ferrigno holy
Sh primal fear Richard Gere never played
The Incredible Hulk time Ed Norton
[Music]
I've got to capture this moment on you
get in there we'll take a quick little
selfie first peak of the devil there's
Ryan now probably calling begging for
help
ignore this is not a game max guys It's
A Wrap in here okay show's over
so this isn't the end of this whole
thing no it is the end okay you said
whoever catches you get the car we found
you car game oh how about that
ridiculous fight was that real in this
gun real oh no Andy Oh
[Music]
goodness to what the bastion and I owe
the pleasure
well we were all just talking and we
realized we haven't had a game night hey
just just the seven of us no I thought
you were going to your brother's house I
never said that
come on dear baron live a little it's a
weekend we were just saying how you were
always better at games and Debbie was I
think he not too besmirched my ex-wife
that woman is an angel oh yeah she was
much better against than you well and I
have eagerly awaited a visit such as
this
but he go Jerry fella yeah it seems like
Ryan you good guys I'm scared
we don't need a board and we do not need
pieces don't need an extra rudeness
either got to burn this door down you're
gonna light a fire in a windowless room
well it's only gonna be dangerous until
the door bars down two words bill Siegel
oh wait I don't like this
honey don't look at huh raided our
[Music]
tonight we're gonna take game night up a
notch Oh baby Amy those matches about to
burn this door down you're gonna light a
fire in a windowless room that we're
trapped in well it's only gonna be
dangerous until the door burns down
[Music]
squeaky toy the pain
rated-r february 23rd we're down to two
teams so for double points what is the
name of the purple Teletubby Susie vici
you're both correct he always carried a
red purse max is very competitive as am
i it's one of the reasons I fell in love
with him oh that's easy
he was an incredible whole Arab an other
one mark ruffalo other one lou ferrigno
primal fear Richard Gere never played
the incredible time Jesus Christ
Norton guys what do you say we do this
at my house next week
this will be a game night to remember oh
boy tonight we're taking game night up a
notch we don't need a board and we do
not need pieces we won't need an extra
rudeness either someone in this room is
going to be taken
oh I said murder mystery party fine
whoever finds the victim wins the grand
prize the keys to stingray chess Vicky's
no Ryan the whole car oh yeah this is
what I'm Kristy the best a lot all right
bye baby having those matches about to
burn this door down you're gonna light a
fire in a windowless room that we're
trapped in I gotta make my idea sounds
stupid
you're not gonna know what's real what's
fake
is this gun real Oh oh my god I always
enjoyed that comradery of good friends
stuff and we don't appreciate what we
have until it's gone
oh because your wife left you
[Music]
so much worse okay I have one idea it's
so crazy it just might work
you're gonna crash the car to the flame
like Liam Neeson in taken three he did
that in taking three huh
you missed it thanks baby
this is instructions on how to remove a
bullets didn't have rubbing alcohol so I
got you this lovely sharp good idea way
to pivot what is helpful in country
living
oh that's the latest there's a corn
chowder recipe looks really good huh
he loves my chowder dude yeah that's you
you